so what do you do man
you're not making music man really
staying in shape working out you know
you know what i'm saying to be honest i
don't be boxing to nothing like that
i'll be seeing a lot of rappers posting
boxing videos embarrassing that damn
self i ain't one of them guys i don't do
that but you know i you know definitely
stay in shape defend myself and all of
that so
i'm good i can fight though
yeah [ __ ] be boxing on camera i'll be
like man chill the [ __ ] out man like
these things be looking crazy so they
have
stop posting these boxing videos for a
[ __ ] come test your hands for real
though straight up they can handle she's
six nine
i took i could handle takashi 69
that's like a pit bull in a chihuahua
that [ __ ] like five three man
yeah really
[ __ ] like that get [ __ ] up
right you know what i'm saying like
ain't nothing tough about a guy like
that so here's the speech impediment huh
who who got a speech repetitive takaichi
takashi 69 yeah
i don't know i just think you know he's
a little mexican [ __ ] he just
say [ __ ] a lot
i don't need i like some of his songs
when he first came out i like that [ __ ]
i ain't with that snitching [ __ ] but you
know he was a good artist though
[ __ ] can't really take that away
from him he's a good artist he's
definitely
entertaining ass [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying with all that you know when the
[ __ ] get you know until all that legal
[ __ ] on you know i don't really [ __ ]
with that i keep away from tough guys in
this business yeah i'm [ __ ] trouble i
don't [ __ ] with no tough guys all these
[ __ ] in the rap industry rap
the only [ __ ] with [ __ ] is like
fake tough like you don't see no like
rock bands and [ __ ] like that you know
when they hear about no beef like
country singers and [ __ ] like that they
want to make money together exactly you
know what i'm saying so it's like rap
the only [ __ ] with [ __ ] got
these little fake tough egos and [ __ ]
that's why i stated myself i don't
really [ __ ] with too many of these rap
[ __ ] like that i guess it's this
that's just the beginning of rap the
tough guy image yeah man but [ __ ] with
rappers you wanna get [ __ ] up [ __ ]
if you say so
a lot of that [ __ ] be fake man you know
what i'm saying so you know it don't be
the rappers it'd be like they homies
from where they from and [ __ ] like that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up
[Music]